was just over two weeks until the
coronation of King Charles was the
country and the world in the group of
Royal fever well not quite when it comes
to Street parties 16 000 were organized
for the Queen's Platinum Jubilee but
there's only been 361 applications for
the coronation this is reflected in a
new poll with 35 of Brits saying they
don't care very much about it 29 say
they don't care at all well nearly 1400
people who spent to take part in not my
king protests world leaders like
President Biden and top pop stars have
also been snubbing the coronation
um here's the White House's press
secretary diplomatically trying to
explain why
the president had about a 25 minute 30
minute call with the king king uh King
King Charles III and during which he
congratulated the king and they have a
very friendly uh conversation they have
a a good relationship with the King he
talked about uh how he enjoyed meeting
visiting uh the queen I should say back
in 2021 the king offered for him to come
and do a state a state visit which which
the president accepted and uh and so
they will see each other again very soon
and uh I'll just leave it there
if you ever heard a lame lameer or more
tortured excuse for why the president of
the United States isn't coming so has
the crown lost its Shine by joining me
now as author and historian Tessa Dunlop
and King Charles is former Butler Grant
Harold so welcome to both of you
um all right Tessa off you go has it
lost its luster the crown I think we've
maybe got royal ceremonial fatigue the
queen God bless I lived a very long time
so we had a golden jubilee we had a
Diamond Jubilee we had a platinum
Jubilee we had a thumper of a funeral
and now the heirs come out of the
machine and you know because I missed
you when you're in America but I'm gonna
give some of the blame to people like
you and people in the Press peddling
this kind of divisive narrative making
the scars in the royal family deeper
than they really needed rather than the
people doing TV interviews and
best-selling books trashing the royal
family who happen to be members of the
royal family they're not to blame it's
us reporting on the trashing that's the
problem it's a bit like Prince Harry
saying I never accused the Royals of
being racist even though we all heard
about him and Oprah him and Meghan
Markle told Oprah Winfrey no it was the
beastly media over two years falsely
reported it as racism until we've now
corrected them it's so good that you
haven't lost your Pizzazz on the other
side of the Atlantic it's such thing
Tessa it's such Horsemen let me bring in
ground what do you feel about recovery
you work with Prince Charles now it's
now King Charles yeah
um I'm I'm excited by the coronation and
I think that the public probably will
come round quite quickly as they tend to
do for these things I think there'll be
a lot of further building up to the
coronation itself in that week and I
think we'll be surprised by this scale
actually of celebrations for this it's
the first correlation in my lifetime in
most people's Lifetime with fast
Carnation in 70 years and I've always
said that with the queen obviously we
all most people loved her we respected
her as you mentioned she had many
jubilees and celebrations this is the
first for the king you know it's a
beginning film with his new Reign and as
you've said it takes time but I think
you know I know there's in popularity
pools and everything but from the people
I speak to people I know a lot of people
like chem at my home respect him
um but you're in the Royal bubbles those
peers you're in this I'm not in any
Royal bubble we are in a bit of a
cushion bubble where we hear all about
the kind of drip fed into our inboxes oh
this is happening oh that chair's being
polished oh she's wearing that Crown
actually Satan but it is for you I mean
partly because it Butters your bread and
why not but but beyond the sort of
Central London chatterboxes who's this
really speaking to you know in Europe
can you tell me when the last coronation
was in Europe I don't care well I care
1922 peers so what is Britain doing
still wandering around with baubles in a
cost of living crisis I think that the
app because actually the monarchy the
molecule remains something that the vast
majority of this country still respect
and you can have them on it like and
have and I I think the trouble is you
see you being a key supporter of the
Duke and Duchess
of whining what the damage that they've
done Grant I think is actually quite
calculable now well you can see a lot of
the reactions especially in America I've
just been a lot of them saying yeah the
trouble the Roses they're racist aren't
they callous and they're horrible
because Harry says so I mean it's really
quite been quite it's marked and
damaging it certainly been uh upsetting
I mean I felt sorry for the queen
because obviously the entire life this
is what was all going on while Philip
was dying while she was dying there's
these two yapping away pouring more and
more manure over them could you imagine
if it was a former staff member doing it
you know it would be shown it just
wouldn't happen but can we be honest
Grant I bet you and Pierce certainly
peers if I know you even won Iota was
just an incy Wincy bit disappointed that
Megan isn't going to be at that car why
I I think I'll tell you why I'm
disappointed I'm very disappointed
Harry's going to be there I'm very
disappointed that Charles although I
completely understand it as a father why
he's felt the need to do this he doesn't
want to be seen to be the the bad guy in
the in the whole thing but what the hell
is Prince Harry doing having
found me in that that horrible book he
wrote the terrible series they've done
the interviews they've done trashing
trashing trashy trashing damaging the
institution of the monarchy damaging the
royal family and then they have the
brass snake he turns up at the
coronation we know why he's doing it by
the way we know why he's doing it he's
doing it because I suspect Meghan Markle
has gone you better get over there and
get on that balcony somehow because our
entire commercial World depends on you
still being a dominant member of the
royal family let's take a let's take a
reality check on the idea of money in
the commercial world when today we've
just seen it released after
comprehensive investigation by the
guardian the king is the richest royal
ever seen by World kind is it 1.8
billion pounds The Sovereign doesn't
have to pay inheritance tax you can feel
a bit of sympathy for Harry he's been
totally I know zero Queen Charles that's
where our national wealth is they should
be paying for the coronation some money
I'm sure is Dunedin some of the wealth
or something
um you know and I know you know you
could argue about the amount of money
they've got at the end of the day
I think they're good value as well I
think what he does
they're living in a different Fantasy
Land they're members of an institution
which actually went off pays for itself
the tourism money that comes in alone
pays for the costs of us upkeeping the
royal family but if you you got to hand
your Mansion to your children they could
pay for themselves they'd play by a
different set of rules which is why we
judge yes they do and in return they
live in this endless goldfish Bowl they
don't have a lot of the freedoms we
enjoy and have witnessed they do an
unbelievably large number of Duties a
year which by the way your two Heroes
over in California they do zero they do
all they do is take their Royal titles
and sign massive contracts with
companies who only want them for one
thing to trash the family again which is
what they keep doing and that's my
argument against them but maybe the
bigger argument is if the coronation is
a bit paired down if it doesn't deliver
the Razzmatazz that some people expect
of it maybe that's the reality check we
go forward but with a pair down but the
one thing this country the one thing the
wonderful once we've gone through the in
my I mean I voted against it so I can
say this once we've gone through the
ridiculous fast of brexit which is just
clearly not working and is actually
damaging the country or now how many
years after it means seven eight years
after the vote right so I don't see no
evidence of this thing working so we've
become ever more insular and people look
at us and they see Boris Johnson
ridiculous this trust ludicrous we
become a laughing stop the one thing
that we do better than any other country
in the world is Pomp pageantry military
ceremony and we're putting the whole
shebang on in two weeks time and it's a
moment for the light of the world to
shine on my country and we can feel
proud about it it picks people rather
than feeling ashamed and embarrassed
because Boris has done something stupid
again all this trusses tank Global
markets or whatever it may be it appears
if we want to feel proud again then
let's take away the bile let's draw away
the soap operas Harry and Megan but no
because we're still kids we're not
stoking it they're doing it let's join
together I'm happy
media Can't Ignore two members of the
royal family publicly trashing the royal
family it's obviously a huge news story
they've got to stop it can I also see
with the coronation any big celebration
with royal family it brings people
together that's one thing I've noticed
yeah look at them look at them and also
each year they've been in over 500
million from the tourist industry can
you imagine what they're gonna bring in
with the coronation weekend the amount
of people huge absolutely great news is
Harry goes home after the show that is
good news my wife kept my Sunday free
for lunch with you yeah the good news is
he is going straight home and that is
his home his home now is in Montecito in
California in a massive mansion He got
because he sold his family out there's a
word for that it's called traitor anyway
lovely to see you again Tessa nice of
you to make your comeback on our show uh
good to see you too good to see you